[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
well hello everybody and welcome to day
four of the 2018 cote d'ivoire
rapid and blitz invitational where ten
of the very best players in all of
Africa compete for a $15,000 prize fund
my name is Ben Simon I'm Robert and a
ski and we have excitement for you
because today is the blitz this is a
full round robin of blitz you'll be
seeing here today at chest 24 calm and
tomorrow we'll finish it up with the
final rounds but you know I welcomed
everybody to the Cote d'Ivoire rapid and
blitz Invitational we could be saying
welcome to the bossom amine show because
that's what's been happening today
Robert yeah and just now they were able
to stop this furious winning streak that
bossom amine was on I mean he had won
something like six games in a row
well a grand total of nine games in a
row he won all six of his book that his
first blitz games today and his seventh
round he just was drawn against by
Moakley cell at nany so the streak is
over yeah Wow and I mean this tournament
it's is the book shut at this point has
he clinched this thing I think so I mean
we have nine rounds left tomorrow plus
the two rounds that we're going to be
covering right now but considering that
you know these games aren't weighted as
the rapid portion was I think it's
pretty much in the bag because he's
established they have to leave I mean
something like six points so right well
he was the favorite coming in let's take
a look at the field that is competing in
this tournament if you're joining us for
the first time this is the range of
characters we have the best players in
Africa three of the top ten players by
feat a ranking 10 players 10 nations
represented with grandmaster dr. bossom
amin at the top by any metric 200 points
higher than his opponents now let's take
a look at the tournament format if
you're not familiar this is the same
format as the rapid and blitz events in
the Grand chest tour although not a part
of the tour it's directly using those
rules now for the past three days we've
seen rapid play a full round-robin
played and they
playing for the handicap on how they
were coming in today how many points
ahead of everybody else are you gonna be
because each game was worth two points
now it's regular blitz one point per
game a half point for a draw today and
tomorrow nine rounds today nine rounds
tomorrow and keep in mind there's no
increment in these games game in five
minutes with a three-second delay this
is gonna be fast this is gonna be
furious and very very exciting from
Abidjan in the Ivory Coast but let's
take a look at the standings this so
this is after blitz round seven okay
today we have round eight and we have
round nine so it's after blitz round
seven but you can see that blossom Amin
there we go is 21 and a half points
grand total unbelievable Robert not it's
over it's there's not I mean okay well
hey so here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna look at some of the contenders
here feature guys like mohammed hadas
and kenny solomon it hey they're playing
in the next round by eight by the way so
we'll we'll see you know who's gonna be
in second place while keeping Basilan
main in our pocket as as our expected
winner so we're gonna take a look at
some of today's games here in just a
moment but i'd like to address the prize
fund because you know this is the
richest prize fund in the history of
quick tournaments in all of Africa talk
to me about the money I will $15,000
grand total online money and that boss
of a mean first prize well I'm gonna try
my best at Jenks the guy by the way
first place $5,000
what a tournament and what a time to be
a competitor at Hotel teamö right now
this is really something and we have
some live video will be bringing to you
today of some of these blitz games gonna
be very important to see as much as we
can of the board because like we said
the actions can be really fast and I
know you were looking at the games
earlier Robert of action that happened
in the seven rounds today already yeah
well
no when we looked at rapid games we sort
of hold the players up to a certain
standard and they didn't disappoint us
because the games were very interesting
and very you know complicated sparks
were flying pretty much on every turn
however I think that's kind of unfair
you know when we're talking about blitz
you know emotions are riding high like
you mentioned you know there's there's
money at play and maybe play becomes a
little bit too speculative so instead of
focusing on you know trying to dissect
the profound ideas I thought we should
look at some of the bloopers you know
some of the the Blitz bloopers the Blitz
bloopers absolutely what round do we
have here are you looking at Blitz round
let's see what I have here I wanted to
start off with a game from round four
between Andrew Conde and bossom amine
now tonight at the right round here I
think you're in round five right I am
okay so give me okay blitz four is what
we're looking for
what's for Andrew K on day of Zambia the
sixth time Zambian National Champion
okay actually I pulled up a different
game because I messed up all the round
numbers but this is still one of the
games that I wanted to talk about
between kaduche and Silva all right from
cells four didn't really want to go
through the whole game but I did think
that there was an interesting blunder
here in this position White has defended
very well and got a pretty complicated
position out of the opening and just
when it seems like he's out of the woods
plays the move rook d1 allowing Queen
takes d5 just winning a piece in one
move look at this now after a takes d5
you're not only going to lose your piece
you're gonna lose a second piece mr.
rook takes e to check the King moves and
your Bishop is also hanging so this is a
fairly common pattern once you've
defended a difficult position you let
your guard down and you miss some silly
tactic so we're going to be seeing a lot
of this today and probably in the rounds
to come as well you know I was playing
some blitz outside the Chess Club just
last night and maybe we'll see some
games that will remind me of
street games we were playing last night
I was watching some of your games yeah
they would be up here as well yes but
anyway I wanted to pull up another funny
position is this from what round is this
this is from the same round this is
round five and okay to be fair blacks
position is anything but encouraging but
after Bishop c5 black could still try to
maybe run away with asking after King f8
Bishop takes pawn takes Queen takes King
g8 and white is up a healthy pawn has
connected passed pawns in the center but
instead black thought to threaten
checkmate in one move just usually not a
bad idea but here after rook e1 oh we
saw it yeah he didn't see it actually he
played Queen takes e7 which fortunately
is still good enough and a black
resigned because if you go King to f8
I'm still gonna win your queen and if
you go King to have six well I take your
Bishop and you're not threatening
checkmate anymore so after Queen takes
you seven black resigned so and we just
want to remind you as we are about seven
minutes away from blitz round eight you
can watch all of the games live at chess
24 calm and be sure to check out Africa
chess Mediacom for all the stories and
updates regarding this tournament
excellent so those two games I just
showed you were from one single round we
have nine rounds today seven has already
happened so I'm gonna let you do some of
the math on that and round eight is
coming up pretty soon right
yeah just about five minutes away at the
half-hour mark alright so you want to
see a couple more yeah let's take crazy
blunders at least read more I dig it
so here we have a game from our well if
I want to drink some - I would call him
our soon-to-be champion but that beat
that's your thing we're really trying to
jinx in right yeah I even believe in
jinx it
well anyway Boston Amin has been playing
the King's Indian like an expert and
it's
trysting because he plays very similar
systems with white and with black so he
plays the Kings Indian attack as white
and then he plays a Kings Indian his
black and he's been getting good
positions in pretty much every game this
was not the exception so the knight on
c6 is hanging and the first thing when
one of your pieces is threatened your
first reaction is probably let me move
it away right so with a move like Knight
takes e5 maybe Knight takes pawn takes
it does look like blacks position is
better the white king is exposed
I'm sure bossom was feeling pretty
comfortable at this point however white
thought well let me protect my knight
and unfortunately after Queen d5 you're
setting yourself up for a nasty pin and
after Knight a5 your knight is trapped
on c6 so another unfortunate blunder
here and not the only blunder of the
round in fact there was a marathon game
between a lad nonny and Rocko Toma Haro
I think I'm getting closer to
pronouncing that name correctly but
let's see if I can find the correct
position here after Bishop c4 white
played rook a8 now when you look at this
position the last thing that comes to
your mind is that white actually won
this game because if we do a quick count
of the pieces we see that black is about
to win a bishop and in the game he
played Bishop takes f1 which was a huge
blunder because now after Bishop d6
what's gonna get the piece back but here
black could have played the simple Brook
takes f1 check and after King G to
Bishop d5 King takes f1 Bishop takes a
eight and we retain our extra piece now
missing these kinds of opportunities
usually carries a high cost and in this
game carried the highest because it was
actually white who ended up winning so
Rocco tomorrow definitely kicking
himself for this one and now both of
these players as it stands right now
going into round eight are thirteen and
a half points I mean if you if you take
out possum I mean that the rest of the
field is pretty close you know yeah kind
of exciting to see who's gonna the
standings for second place or wide-open
you know there's plenty of excitement
for the rest of the field you could say
but I think Fossum Amin is in the
driver's seat
and the thing is he's playing so well
that you know it's not like he's you
know swindle his opponents in lost
positions he's playing very well so
there's no reason to believe that he's
not gonna be able to keep up this pace
so that's what uh what impresses me the
most yeah now he's playing like there
really is a 200 point rating gap between
him and the rest of the yeah so in the
long run it seems like these gaps in
rating do have some correlation we have
less than three minutes until round
number eight Robert do we dare take a
look at another one
anything you can handle it I need I
don't know can you handle it I can
handle I got two more for you from round
seven well it around it just let's do
one more let's do one all right all
right round so here we have a position
between the game Suwannee and Silva
after Queen c7 I think black is pretty
happy I mean he got this Knight on the
beautiful f5 outpost and he's got a
better pawn structure we see this white
has an isolated pawn on h4 backward pawn
on f2 but nevertheless these are
weaknesses that white should be able to
keep control of however white got a
little bit too excited here played f4
and after 93 got forked
in exchange and actually very soon
blundered another piece well upon in
this case after Knight takes d4 you know
white said okay that's enough
today this is not my game and simply
resigned and in this same round the game
between rocket Omaha Roe and Paula da
boo adieu also led to an interesting
blunder but a blunder that in this case
wasn't really taken advantage of so we
see white completely dominating in this
position along the C file and after the
move rook takes c6 black isn't able to
play rook takes c6 because after D takes
rook takes we have Queen d5 check and we
pick up the rook so instead black
figured okay I'll just leave that rook
on c6 and everything will be okay so he
played F takes e4 and funny thing after
Queen c2 black has no moves because
we're threatening to play rook takes c7
and if rook takes c6 no D takes c6 Queen
c7 C takes D 7 and you can take my queen
on c2 but now I'm gonna take your rook
with check and when you take back for it
takes we start counting the pieces and
we see that white is very much ahead in
material and pretty much a reasonable
position but instead white plays played
F takes d4 of course his position was
amazing and he ended up winning anyway
but I thought that was a nice little
tactic so how are we doing with the time
well the rounds have just gotten the
round 8 has just doesn't what am I
saying gotten underway so let's take a
look at the matchups that we'll be
seeing in blitz round number 8 and you
can see at chest 24 calm now we're going
to be focusing on one game almost
exclusively per round since it's blitz
it's gonna be fast and it's gonna be
furious and this round let's take a look
at number 2 versus number 3 in the live
standings
talking about Grandmaster Mohammed I
mean a douche against Grandmaster Kenny
Suliman it's Algeria verse is South
Africa so right now we actually do have
a live image if it's possible to pull it
up of how do SH and Solomon at the board
it's unclear if we can if we have that
but let's take a look there that well
that's pretty cool yeah the magic of
Facebook live how about that and we got
to give a shout out to Babatunde hogan
siku the head of african chess media he
is the one who is basically manning this
camera right now allowing us to see this
so we get into a scramble this is gonna
be very helpful so what do we have so
far Robert so this was an Italian
opening it's pretty clear usually what
we want to look out for in the Italian
opening at least as black is that our
light squares don't become too weak
especially these f5 and d5 squares so
black is playing d5 with the hope that
white is gonna go something like a takes
and after Queen takes expose the sweet
backward phonon d3 which is going to be
very easy to pressure along the D file
so generally speaking against d5 we
don't want to take he takes d5 unless we
can create some King side attack based
on a quick Knight g3 Knight f5 and who
knows maybe even some sacrifices on aged
six but for that we would already need
the Queen on f3 the night on g3 the
knight on it going to f5 so I'm guessing
white is gonna play something like Queen
f3 so actually that's exactly what
happened in the game so after d5 Queen
f3 d4 takes takes Queen b6 and HG 327 to
be 497 so we see black taking some
measures to take these squares under
control so Knight f1 rerouting the night
to e3 and again eyeing that f5 and d5
squares let's see how black is gonna
answer here so if you can never go g6
because then your age six pawn is gonna
be hanging
let's not forget there's a bishop still
on c1 here so also maybe after 93 we're
gonna be able to play Bishop takes whoa
what happened what happened
did we lose is that the same game it is
what's going oh there we go it's back
there we go
scary I have no idea what happened okay
all right I was testing you so good test
so black goes Knight h7
so hoping maybe to play something like
Knight to g5 and neutralize the action
of the bishop on c1 and maybe trying to
you know make your queen retreat a
little bit because this Queen looks
somewhat threatening on f3 and maybe now
it's not going to be so easy to play
Bishop e3 Bishop takes Knight takes
because after Knight g5 you're gonna
have some pressure against efore for
example if Queen e2 I don't think I can
go g6 yet because then you can go h4 and
well I could do this actually
so after Knight h7 white plays Knight f5
hoping that against Knight takes pawn
takes this will expose the pawn on b7
and this kind of pawn structure would be
very sad for black because now we're
going into an endgame with a completely
shattered Queen side this is not good of
course we shouldn't rush to take these
pawns because now after Bishop takes f2
King takes we simply lose the exchange
so we need to be a little bit careful
but with that beautiful pawn structure I
think that white would be close to
winning in that endgame so we can't
really take on f5 yet now maybe we can
play something like Knight g5 again
trying to destabilize this Queen so that
after Bishop takes pawn takes we can try
to kick this night out with g6 not have
to be afraid of art
we pulling on aged six so let's see if
we have some moves
is this actually what happened you took
and played queen c6 I have a hard time
believing maybe this is the live shot
shows the Queen on e6 yeah no so this is
just the analysis they haven't made or
oh this actually did happen yeah okay
five and play Queen c6 I'm very
surprised actually it looks like the the
live video is actually on more of a
delay than the board which is bizarre
maybe but we do have this endgame on the
board and I I can't believe like went
for this I mean what if I just go Bishop
III instead of taking on a6 which is
what we were looking at now imagine
something like Bishop takes Knight takes
okay you go Knight f6 I go Knight c4 but
I have all these nice targets right on
the Queen side and in the center this
endgame should be close to lost so after
Bishop e3 black played Bishop b6 hoping
that you'll jump the gun and take on b6
allowing black to fix this pawn
structure a little bit that White Rose
rook a for intending to double up on the
a file and gang up on this isolated a6
pawn so do we have any more moves rook a
for it's black to move black is probably
thinking oh man what did I get myself
into when black is now looking at a big
time deficit remember this is game in
five with just a three-second delay yeah
so usually the time trouble follows the
bad position because when you think oh I
made a mistake my positions bad then you
have to start solving a lot more
problems than you would if you were say
on the pressing side so I'm sure that
black is trying to find some counter
attacking move with rookie 5 to put
pressure on f5 but I don't think that
would really solve much because let's
say I go g4
now if you go a five I'm not going to
play B takes a five and trade off one of
your main weaknesses instead I'm just
going to increase the pressure with rook
a1 and at some point I will take on a5
when it wins material so let's see in
the game after rook a4 black went Knight
to f6 so hoping maybe to bring this
Knight to d5 so I'm wondering what does
black have in mind after the move rook
a1 because if you go Knight d5 I think I
can just take here and after takes takes
if you know you trade everything on III
this endgame is not really gonna help
you too much because I don't know if you
ever heard this idea but rooks it's a
general principle more than idea rooks
are the best piece to take advantage of
pawn weaknesses
so when you see pawn weaknesses on the
board you should usually try to keep
your rooks on it that is if your
opponent is the one with the pawn
weaknesses if you have the weaknesses
try to trade off all the rooks as soon
as possible so it's important not to
think of rook end games as dryish which
i think is a common mistake also you see
this a lot with opposite color bishops
so let's see after Knight to f6 white
played the move c4 I'm not so sure about
this move it looks like it weakens the
b4 pawn and now black is going for some
counter play along the B file I think c4
was a mistake because now if you go rook
takes a 6 rook takes b4 rook takes c6 I
could go rook takes b2 maybe I didn't
have enough time to go rip e7 I don't
know maybe just rook takes b2 rook takes
d7 and try to get both of my rooks on
the 7th rank if black is able to achieve
this you should have enough compensation
for the pawn so this is actually what
happened in the game
you're right there might be a little bit
of a lag on the camera right because
unless we can see the future
can we I don't know
yeah rook takes b2 rook takes e7 and
this is what we have but I think black
has done some progress here because this
rook can come to a eight and eight to
true we're down upon and it's a fairly
important pawn because this could easily
get out of hand for us especially since
we don't have the C 2 square for our
rook to try to control this pawn because
the knight is controlling c2 I'm sure
white is still better but I'm thinking
okay if something like rook a8 c5 rook a
- I can always go rook f1 probably and
I've neutralized your main threat and
now I can start pushing my C pawn but
also this rook the rook generally
doesn't want to be in front of its pawn
it wants to be in back so if this c7
Brooke we're on c1 I would say white is
probably winning but whoa so what's
going on here what is going on here
so after rook takes c7 black went rook
b8 rook a1 rook c8 takes takes oh he
went for a different approach he's just
trying to stop this pawn from moving
forward rook c5 g4 King f8 King G 298
row 37 rook c6 so
black tried to buckle down say okay I'm
just gonna do damage control I'm not
trying to get active play and compensate
the pawn I'm just trying to hold you
back and put pressure on c4 and maybe
after 96 I can actually get my pawn back
and let's not forget that if white loses
this pawn or even if we trade c4 for
efore this four against three that white
is going to have left on the kingside
it's probably not going to be enough to
win the game so that is a very
interesting defensive strategy so after
Knight o98 kingi 396 c5 a little bit of
a tactic you can't take the pawn because
the knight is hanging so the knight has
to go back but how are you going to
protect this guy no I think blacks
defensive strategy here is paying off I
think that if something like this
happens
Black has very good chances of holding
because what it's not gonna be able to
create at least not easily a passed pawn
with these doubled pawns so so what do
you think it might be a drop with the
best plan here yeah and even with not
necessarily best play you do have some
margin of error as black here and this
is actually what happened after what did
we see ninety-eight rook d5 Knight f6
rookie 597 rook takes rook takes e5 and
we get to this four against three which
I don't really see amounting to much I
mean sure
white is gonna try to push a little bit
but I'm fairly optimistic about blacks
position considering how terrible it was
at that point when we transitioned from
the opening slash middle game to this
ending and we could just see in the
lower-right the players blitzing off a
few moves they're down to just a bit
well Kenny's down to about 10 seconds if
you want to see these games live go to
chess 24 calm you'll see the live
digital boards right there receipt black
maybe a threatening a nice little tactic
here with Knight takes f5 getting back
that pawn so how can white deal with
this maybe just get the rook out maybe
g6 with the idea that if you go Knight
takes f5 I go rook takes f7 check and
I'll take the knight on the next note so
whoa these moves are coming in fast so
we just skip to the newest position
right yep okay so actually I'm kind of
curious to see how we got here so right
after rook d7 check routes before f6 so
takes takes C in it I'm not so crazy
about playing the move f6 I would have
gone g6 trying to get rid of my double
pawns but here this item game usually
Knight end games are considered similar
to King and pawn in games so if you want
to know how you're doing in the night
end game just take the Knights off the
board and try to evaluate the King and
pawn endgame
if you reach the conclusion that the
king and ponen game is winning then
adding Knights shouldn't really change
the evaluation so that's kind of a handy
practical rule so let's see after some
maneuvering we get this position and
there's all these players that are going
so fast can we get a full shot of the
board by chance oh nice
yep so 94 Keaney 490 so yeah like really
wants to chop down that f2 pawn that way
you can sacrifice his knight for the
remaining pawn and it's just an easy
drawing to do remember we don't have
increment here so three second delay
that's all you get
black only has eight seconds left and is
banking on that three second delay now
do you know if an illegal move loses the
game or do you get to I I believe I
don't think it'll lose the game no
because Knights are pretty tricky that
way you know it's very easy to to forget
that you're in check I've actually lost
the game recently that way
yeah I mean this is played under the
auspices of the Ivorian Chess Federation
in Fiji I'm sure so if they're playing
by fidei rules the rule currently states
that you get two illegal moves before
you lose the game is that a recent rule
change I feel it is it is before before
with one illegal move you lost the game
immediately now you get two you get two
strikes well we're getting a little
grainy okay we're back this is a long
distance video right here folks
yeah so I think this is just gonna
fizzle out into a drawing the problem
when you have such little time is that
you're kind of in denial you know you
you don't have enough time to really
make a cold assessment of the position
I'm sure both sides know that it's a
draw but they just want to you know take
a second to to breathe and just ask
themselves okay what's going on here
now Mike needs to be a little bit
careful here because what just happened
he's moving his King a little bit too
far away from the f7 pawn I do she's put
what does that mean what does that
gesture yeah I mean you're doing this a
lot I'm like the is he claiming like his
opponent made an illegal move or
something well he didn't make an
official claim yeah maybe yeah maybe
he's thinking that there's a rep yeah I
think I think there was something odd
going it looks like me and my opponent
outside yesterday a little bit yeah oh
no come on come on although hadoo she's
hollering that pink drink that you had
what was that it was a cranberry juice
it's delicious
it was only cranberry juice of course
okay maybe well it looks like we lost
the video feed but the game is a draw
yep so that means that both of the
players they get a half point they were
tied at 14 and so now they will I think
they were tied at 14 so now they're 14
and a half each so still tied for second
as oh please we can understand whether
we're playing that game out because a
win would have positioned them in clear
second oh absolutely and it's so
important right now I mean you're
talking about a difference of a grant
you know but all of the games have been
completed we're gonna have some time to
take a look at some of the other games
that happen that round but before we do
let's glance at the standings with just
one blitz game left to go today okay
yeah Fossum I mean it looks like he won
again no surprise there but then we have
15 and a half points yeah pardon me my
math was incorrect fifteen and a half
points for kaduche and Salomon and that
a little bit of a logjam after that
four-way time for fourth I mean
we kind of know who the major players
are gonna be at this point will glance
at some of the games as they happen but
what one of the games catch your eye
here Robert for from round number 8 well
I'm always gravitating towards the
bossom game right yeah because you know
he's can't stop winning it's like he
can't not win even if he tries well he's
he's up first of all he's undefeated in
this entire tournament
yeah he's undefeated he's had a
nine-game winning streak that crossed
over from the rapid to the blitz and
just ended today I mean it was mostly
today but do you remember what the last
game he played was before that winning
streak started no do you remember that
game when he where he blundered his
Queen he was down a queen for basically
nothing in an end game he had like queen
against the rook it was some ridiculous
position that he ended up drawing we
interviewed him after how can you yeah
right yeah it was it was the second day
yeah yeah and I said okay this could be
a turning point in the tournament
because when you have this lucky break
then everything starts falling into
place
and sure enough after that game bossom
won
what was it nine games in a row three in
the rapid six and the Blitz then he drew
one game and now he won again so he's
got 10 and a half out of the last 11
that's pretty impressive pretty good
alright but in blitz number eight he had
the black pieces against all Adamu I do
from yeah a quick look at this let's see
what's going on so he goes for the
King's Indian again and this is what I'm
telling you he he knows his systems and
when you want to study an opening one of
the best things that you can do is find
a player that you think understands the
system well and you know since bossom is
also a professional chess player you can
bet he's done some research and analyzed
his openings and maybe come up with a
few new ideas of his own and once you
find this player just study his games
really well
and tried to emulate that play and the
interesting thing about Amin is that he
plays these systems both with white and
with black so I don't know if I was
playing in the tournament
I would simply try to find a way to
avoid his systems you know that he seems
to understand so well so he clearly
favors Kings Indian type of pawn
structure so maybe why not play E 4
against him instead of D for preventing
the Kings Indian
so now after Knight takes before rook c4
and I think we have another blunder
blooper of the day oh boy this is not
where you want your Knights to be right
I mean at first I thought like we just
go Bishop takes and after Knight takes
Bishop takes you get two minor pieces
for a rook but you know this is still
fairly complicated but now it looks like
you're just gonna lose a knight Bishop
d2 Bishop takes a four and it's game
over
so rou k-19 c5 and okay being up a piece
he usually wins without material
advantage if you do him extra piece he
usually does pretty well when he's down
a queen as well so give him an extra
piece and this should be a walk in the
park and sure enough you won this game
so let's move on to what do we have here
Sylva against Ella Donnie let's see what
happened in this game so we have a four
night Sicilian Knight takes c6 it's kind
of a tricky move order because if you
target this d6 square you might soon
find yourself playing a special kind of
Sicilian after E 5 Bishop g5 is a direct
transposition so Knight takes c6 is the
most direct approach and after E 5 95 94
Queen c7 f4
between b6c for Bishop b4 King II - this
is a really fun line it's a line that
I've tried to play with both white and
black and I just can't get you know the
hang of it because it's fun to put your
King on f3 on move 10 normally not
something you get to do too often and
you know live to tell the tale
but in these lines it does seem like
white is doing pretty well so after
Bishop c5 c6 Bishop d4 I'm starting to
think I should take that back this does
not look good for white anymore now c5
Bishop e7 is coming I think
shouldn't white simply take a tasty 6
and after Knight f6 maybe try to trade
Queens before this King gets checkmated
this looks a little bit more promising
that what happened in the game so after
Bishop d4 King f3 c 5h for this King is
running but even if you can avoid
getting checkmated black still has the
bishop pair
he's got pressure on the Queen side it's
got better King safety
well actually white has the bishop pair
as well but I almost can't even tell so
the Queen d8 da for me g5 h g5 Bishop
takes a 2 so sometimes you know I'm
looking through these games I'm thinking
what a nice position for black and then
8 I see this that it says that white 1
I'm like wondering okay where where's
the blender or when's the blender coming
so now I see the tides are definitely
turning this Queen trade really helped
white a lot because when you can define
who has better King safety that should
pretty much tell you who was a Queen
trade is gonna favor so this K on g3 was
feeling very insecure when the Queen's
were on the board so I really didn't
like this maneuver Queen d8 Queen takes
g5
that black plate now Bishop takes ecigs
and oh nice little tactic after pawn
takes check King f8 Bishop takes at the
8th and black can just resign here so
seems after Bishop takes c6 this game is
pretty much over some more tactics it
fourth takes Bishop rook c8 is checkmate
I believe that pins the game rook e8
rook c4 and I mean I wouldn't call this
a blooper because blacks position is
already pretty bad but this is pretty
much over right takes then we're down a
piece and we still have bad King well
maybe black can fix the King problem but
at a great cost now he's down a piece
and this game is over
alright you know Robert we're living in
a golden age of chess technology I mean
just the fact that we can do this is
amazing yeah one of the improvements
that I would really like to see and it
would be very important in blitz events
is to have each move time-stamped to see
how much time is remaining on that
player's clock whenever they make silly
moves you know yeah because that's part
of the story the thing though is if you
haven't moved its time stamped the game
is going by so fast you really have are
you really just gonna read how much time
I can compare how much time they spend
here or there well no I mean it's easy
it's it'll be fun for commentary
purposes oh maybe okay yeah I think
after the game's over it's like the time
never it never happened yeah you know
the control but you you can't see that
part of the story yeah and I think it
was in the Soviet Union that they taught
the players to actually record you know
on their score sheet to keep a record of
the times they spent on each move sure
themselves and their opponent this was
considered a technique to avoid getting
into time trouble so you could keep an
accurate record about what point in the
game you were spending all your time on
you know maybe you were spending too
much time in the opening not enough time
allotting enough time for the endgame
and then you
making a lot of blunders in the endgame
of course we're talking about classical
chess in that situation yeah but I think
you could also extrapolate some ideas if
you apply this to blitz just the problem
is when you're playing blitz you don't
have time to notate the game so if you
have some kind of recording device to do
that for you oh yeah so in case you're
wondering
our final blitz round of the day blitz
nine starts in less than three minutes
and you can watch along with us at chess
24 comm look for C IV rapid and blitz C
IV is the trigram of course for sevdah
voir o the Ivory Coast okay
I was running so what else did we have
from rounding so we looked at a couple
of games already we saw Silva Ellen on E
we saw I do against Amin yes and we have
a couple of other games while we saw
live right the hadoo SH against Salomon
right did we did we glanced at all the
games no we got two left
okay so let's see what happened in the
game Bellco diya against Rocco Toma har
oh by the way Rocco tomorrow I think is
one of the players we're gonna have to
watch this next round bye oh it's
Ricardo mehar oh he kind of glanced over
the H yeah I remember that thing I
noticed that as well yeah Rocco tomorrow
this is good it sounds it sounds cool
yeah like I forgot already what you said
it's a great interview yeah just I'll
deal with it
don't worry yeah you got this okay so
let's see opening it looks like it was a
ratty opening now normally when you play
rook e8 is because you're trying to play
e5 so I don't know how White's pawn was
able to get to e5 so quickly this might
be giving white an advantage already
perhaps instead of going a5 a4 so
quickly black should try to reinforce
this idea which I
was was interesting but maybe if you
after efore if you take and go a five
you might run into night see for putting
pressure on e5 may be threatening 96 I
don't know if this pawn is hanging maybe
you can just go rook e1 and it does seem
like all of whites pieces are in play
not so much blacks so opening up the
position could simply be good for white
here so maybe this is already better for
white so after a 5-4 a 45 this looks
suspicious to say the least
so rook e1 clearly trying to play for a
six so Knight f8 taking control of the
e6 square rookie 1c v d4 takes takes a
knight c6 so at least blacks pieces are
coming out but what should still be
better shouldn't you mean this a 5 point
usually guarantees a little bit of an
advantage so let's see what happened
took everything on D form played a six
Queen B three rook c8 h4 yeah so
whenever you have a pawn on e5 this
doesn't let your opponent defend the
King side as well as he would like to
because the knight on f6 is the natural
defender of your King so when you chase
it away with E 5 you're always gonna
have to be worrying a little bit about
King safety and the normal pattern is to
go pawn to h5 open up the H file see if
you can get something going Robert we
might have to hurry this up because the
next round is just about to get underway
all right all right don't worry I don't
mean to rush you get in there I'm
getting there I just really want to see
because I thought I saw there was like a
mating attack and this is starting to
look pretty dangerous for black because
white is really restricting black's
pieces
so now g4 and f5 is coming black try to
sacrifice an exchange to get some play
along the light squares but this game is
over now I mean you're up in exchange
you got the attack let's see how white
finish this game off so 96 you're down a
piece basically as Bishop h8 so even if
you just trade Queens and play the
endgame should win pretty easily so it
takes check check and game over
nice little tactic if f6 you can
sacrifice the Queen and give check me so
nice attacking game by Bill Cody oh yeah
good job to the Tunisian yeah he's
definitely having a better leg of the
tournament with the Blitz than the rapid
right I me and Rico tomorrow is he's
still I mean he's still one of the top
contenders in this thing if we can let's
take a look at this enough the standings
with the pairings going into round
number 9 this is what we have to look
forward to and I think the one that
sticks out to me is that one right in
the middle 5 Rico tomorrow against
Muhammad I mean kaduche and we're
following these two players because well
hadoo sh right now is live tied for
second place by our fear Akkad Omaha is
tied for in that big tie for 4th place
so I think this is definitely the game
of the round to watch okay so I'm still
working on some live video here but the
game should be active right now Robert
yep I've pulled up round 9 is there
anything that strikes your fancy yes
absolutely I've got to go with fever KO
tomorrow against Muhammad huh douche all
right game right up I just wanted to
mention real quick that in the Boston
amine game look at the kind of pawn
structure that we're getting kind of
opening are we beginning to see a
pattern emerge well I mean this just
plays into his hands yeah exactly I mean
it's unreal how many games he's able to
play he has been able to play his system
but okay I digress let's go to the Arco
tomorrow game so what do we have here we
have a perk defense
not a king's indian again the king's
indian would evolve having a pawn on c4
but the ideas are going to be quite
similar I think usually black plays the
perk as a way of improving on the King's
Indian because you figure okay
the knight is misplaced on c3 if it's in
front of its own pawn as opposed to the
Kings Indian where it's actually
protected by the pawn on c4 nevertheless
I think the FERC has a maybe
undeservedly bad reputation you
mentioned the other day the book perk
alert so do you play the perk no not at
all
no that's just a great title for a
little book ever
it's got it like punctuated circular
circular circular yeah do you think
anybody told me you know it's hurts me
enough here
no I've cared they probably would have
chosen a different title pronunciation
was a big deal a director is making sure
that we know it's Puetz
yeah Hertz alright so we see this game
progressing with the Mosby five and a
three and already we see one of the
advantages of the perk as opposed to the
King's Indian
since white doesn't have such a good
grip on the Queen side because he
doesn't have a pawn on c4 this is gonna
give black the possibility to expand on
that side of the board would be fine
that's why normally whenever black goes
c6 we automatically play the move a4 so
instead of rook e1 I would have played a
four here containing blacks expansion on
the Queen side no black doesn't have to
give up on this idea but it's gonna take
him a long time to really carry it out
if we play a four because if he goes a
six well still can't play b5 that we can
also play a five and guarantee that a
pawn never gets to be fine because we
can just capture kompis on and after
Queen takes like its left with an
isolated pawn on the a5 so usually black
will have to play b6 ace
Bishop d7 and only then b5 let's see
what's happened in the game so a lot of
moves after b5 a3 Bishop d7 Bishop g5
rookie a community 285 takes takes rook
a d1 in Queen c7 so this is really I
would say a success for black from the
opening point of view we gain space on
the Queen side possibility of b4 is
constant and we also have very good
control over the d5 square so this
knight on c3 doesn't have good prospects
whereas this night on d7 does because at
some point we can try to play Knight c5
put pressure on e4 maybe play rook 88 or
88 white needs to be careful in this
position you could easily run into some
problems especially if we go into an
endgame so here I think white is
counting on the fact that this rook on
d6 can't be chased away so easily
because after rook takes f6 we get two
minor pieces for a rook and this is
generally considered a good trade for
white so after Queen d6
can we trade or can we just simply play
something like Queen b6 trying to target
this queen labor with moves like Bishop
f8 or maybe even just rook 88 and Knight
c5 trapping the Queen so in the game
block trade it on d6 I don't know about
this I mean if we can follow up with b4
this might work
so it's before a problem I don't think
so because we can take although this
would open up the a file for the black
rook and simply move our Knight say to e
2 because we're not afraid of Knight
takes e4 let's not forget that the
knight only 7 is hanging however I don't
like retreating my pieces I don't like
decentralizing in general but retreating
here is not the way to go I think Knight
a 4 is a much better move because our
Knight is more active on a for they're
not eetu and also this black rook
doesn't have as much pressure along the
8 ball and if B takes a 3 B takes a 3 we
can actually use the beef on for our own
Brook so a delicate position okay so
after rook takes d6
black went h6 trying to get this Bishop
out of here and relieve the pressure on
the knight Bishop e3 Bishop f8 rook D
one night c5 yeah and this is what I was
afraid of I think this is an excellent
position for black and the essence of
blacks advantage has to do with his
minor pieces the Black Knights are very
well placed whereas the white knights
not so much notice how these Knights on
f6 and c5 put pressure on e4 we're also
we also have a space advantage on the
Queen side we might be threatening to go
b4 at any moment and win the e4 pawn and
there's something to be said about the
bishops as well because this Bishop on
b7 doesn't look so hot
but we might be able to reroute it BSC 8
& e6 or a six and B 4 and this Bishop on
g2 also doesn't look so great but I
don't see that many possibilities for it
because we couldn't try to go to f1 but
let's not forget we always have to keep
an eye on the e4 pawn so this Bishop is
somewhat restricted by its own pawn so
let's see if we have some more moves
Knight d2 so reinforcing control over
efore now it's just this is the game we
have on the camera yes indeed it is and
we were having a little bit of an issue
earlier but now this is the live shot
okay so it looks like a douche is going
into a deep thing here and now remember
this is on a delay on the on the board
on our dgt board you see that fee is on
move okay so after 92 rook 88 again it's
hard to argue with relaxed position
every piece is centralised now the rook
is coming to the open D file like we
said the Knights are doing great the
bishop on b7 is the only one that
doesn't look like it's living up to its
full potential but as I think what we've
learned in this tournament is how
dangerous the bishops are if we simply
protect them and tuck them away and save
them for later they can spring into
action at any moment and I have been
particularly I would say picky about
this pattern right bringing the rooks to
the center and then dropping the bishops
back to their initial squares so this is
another case where that seems to work
out quite well because notice the
bishops on c8 and f/8 have some pretty
good diagonals so let's see after rook
d8 will work the eighth night b3 Knight
takes pawn takes 97 rook d2 might see
five Brook et1 takes takes and this is
just win upon four black and we just go
Knight takes p3 maybe you can go over
okay d7 but can I go rookie seven or you
go rook the eight now maybe this is a
little bit dangerous so should I go
Bishop c8 and after rook c7 hmm maybe
white is hoping that getting the rook to
the seventh rank is gonna compensate
this pawn that he's down oh okay
nice little move here after rook c7
instead of going Bishop e6 and giving
back the pawn and complain 94 because
after Bishop takes pawn takes this
Knight is under attack and if we start
chasing this pawn and we might find that
this point is chasing us
so after Knight d4 white cannot capture
plate f4 Bishop d6 rook a7 now I see
some blooper potential Oh
and that came out like yeah but yeah
when you see your king and your rook on
the same diagonal and there's bishops on
the board you know you should start
feeling a little bit uncomfortable for
example you know night c2 doesn't really
do much or maybe it does because if you
move your bishop away from the g1 h7
diagonal then we can go Bishop c5 but if
you go to f2 then I can take on f4 so
what's going on here this night C to win
something maybe against nice c2 I can
simply go F takes e5 so we have some
more moves here after
Brook a7 black played Bishop c5 right
away so threatening maybe Knight f3
check and if Bishop takes Bishop takes
III check and then the bishop drops back
and takes the rook - so Rick a8 f6 King
up to g5 that's fine so overall I think
that white has done pretty good damage
control
I mean sure black is up a pawn but this
white rook is active it's putting a
little bit of pressure on 8th my gosh
look at his time look at okay he's
getting down there in about four seconds
oh man so the rooks got traded off and
black is just up a pawn so this end game
should be bad news for white I mean all
we have to do is prepare a timely c5 b 4
or even c5 c4 and start targeting these
pawns
if we do this right away then this night
to come to d5 so maybe start with Bishop
f7 so the fun did get to see for this
point on b2 is gonna be a target forever
White's pieces look kind of cramped -
and we can never take on d4 because then
black just goes Edie for and we have a
pawn nests on the Queen side so
bad news for Rocco Toma record Romero
record on Mahara
Oh tomorrow tomorrow just let it flow it
doesn't flow for me as well as it does
for you I think so yeah it looks like
this game is over the pawn on b2 got
traded for the pawn on c3 and now we're
gonna have to constantly watch out for
the possibility of before let's take a
look at the live shot if we can yeah can
we go to like a full screen look at the
well and look at that just as soon as I
talk its breezes up but I think it's
safe to say right now
Mohamed I mean a douche has won the game
you know so I mean now he's becoming
firmly entrenched as a second-place
competitor in this event mm-hmm so we've
one more game let's switch over quickly
to Abbas of Ameen versus slim Valhalla
that is the last game of the round we
have live we do not have video of that
so we can forget about that and it looks
like bossom in a little bit of trouble
here maybe oh maybe you should be able
to hold but it seems like you're gonna
lose this pawn on g5 okay but he gets to
take on b5 so we should be able to hold
this maybe because after I go Knight
takes g5 let's say I make some move
which moves though let's say I go Bishop
a4 you go Knight takes g5 I go check if
you start chasing after my beep on it
might give me enough time to sack my
bishop for your two kingside pawns so I
think this is yeah
they agreed to a draw here well not here
but let's see what happens after King
takes d5 Bishop takes 96 here 83
yeah it looks like white was able to
sack the pawn from the to the bishop for
the two pawns and secure the draw but
again a strong showing by slim Valhalla
in this blitz portion of the tournament
yes absolutely and it's it's confounding
even with that 200 point advantage the
maximum mean no one has the answer to
the riddle that is Bosma mean he hasn't
lost wrapped in an enigma yes okay
wrapped into something else I need to
think of a word from know uh this is
this is an amazing amazing stuff from
him and if we didn't think he was as
impressive as we expected him to be in
the rapid while he was just getting
warmed up he was yeah exactly and now
the nice thing you know when you secure
such a comfortable lead is that you
don't find yourself in the situation
where you you have to force games and
maybe take unnecessary risks so normally
he might try to push this game for a win
but he was like oh okay if does
anything's gonna be a draw I'm fine with
that I mean I have like a six or seven
point lead I'm just gonna let them come
and get me absolutely yeah now let's
take a look at the standings after our
first day of blitz was just nine rounds
remaining it all goes down tomorrow
right here at chess 24 calm and oh well
it's a little less ambiguous than how we
started the day Robert oh what do you
make of this well I think that first
place is in the bag for bossom amin but
unless there's like a colossal collapse
tomorrow it would be history the last
colossal collapse that's a mouthful so
second place is a different story i mean
uh douche and solomon are really
slugging it out and i could tell from
the video feed of that blitz game
between them they they are not buddies
like they are going all-out for second
place and you know let the chips fall
where they may
that's good to to see that though
because at least around here did you see
like all those hand gestures you know
there was like yeah yeah
well okay so a classical chess if you
asked like the top players in the world
is you know it's the it's the king of
the game right but when you have rapid
and blitz and there's still something
maybe in certain players Minds it's like
it's more in exhibition right there's
all we're all friendly
am I wrong on this absolutely absolutely
yeah I mean I I'm saying I'm glad these
players are very competitive that's what
I like to see no no I mean you were
absolutely wrong because I think that
when you play classical time control you
know you you've got this composure and
you can control yourself and you know
you don't act on impulse in blitz you
let it all out you just show what you're
all about you know you can see a lot of
body language that you usually miss out
on hey what's going on you got your
skype going Skype has the submit'
amazing ability to override your
computer's audio settings it's okay
quite amazing it's the only so I like
blitz because of that I like how you
know players body language really comes
out you can tell when somebody blundered
you can tell when somebody's
uncomfortable you can tell when somebody
doesn't like their opponent too and
that's the most fun do also so you're
saying that the emotion is the same but
in blitz it's more apparent yeah yeah
you don't have time to really like push
it down and control it it's more like it
takes control it's a visceral yeah yeah
so in just a moment we're gonna have
Kenny Solomon back on the show
cool what would you what would you like
to talk to him about in this tournament
any any shining moments for the pride of
South Africa well I'd ask him how he
feels going into the last day because
he's got you know a direct competitor
here with a douche like how does he feel
about his chances against a douche and
this second leg because now they have
another game coming up right because
this is a round-robin event let's not
forget that it's not just nine rounds
it's nine rounds against the same guys
right so you know so you'll be 27 games
played for each player total at the end
of this right but by now they all
probably have a pretty good feel for
each other
like they've played what three games
they've all played each other twice at
this point well no because we had one
leg of blitz as well so we had oh no but
in the rapids ride was okay yeah so they
played twice and so maybe now they can
get like a feel okay this guy I can get
him in the end game or you know his
openings are strong so I should just not
go for too many complications right out
of the gate would they remember all
those details though yeah over this
shorter period of time
oh yeah yeah I mean I remember stuff
that has happened to me like years ago
and I still hold a grudge so I would ask
him you know how he feels about his
chances but specifically as it relates
to his race with a douche for a second
place what do you think would that be a
good question I think that's a great
question I can't wait to talk to him
again now how did he do this now yeah we
still have other games we can look at
actually yeah because he played against
he just won against siguiente and how
did huh dish do i do should also want so
these guys well we just saw the douches
game but let's see what Solomon did
against Suwannee
so d4 d6 have a Queens gambit declined
III a6 takes takes 53 and is this going
to be a minority attack it's one of my
favorite pawn structures and this is
such a good opening and pawn structure
to really learn good chess because it's
not so much that much about forcing
variations as it is about general
principles White's idea is simply to go
b5 take on c6 and play against the
backward pawn what could be more
straightforward than that now
here after Bishop takes e4 Bishop takes
in chief five bishop about five usually
what I expect against 94 is that white
will take on e7 after Queen takes take
on e4 but okay
this seemed to work for white so he gets
a pair of Knights against Knight and
Bishop we have Solomon on the line well
we'll be getting him quite shortly
actual okay so let's see if he actually
managed to get this backward pawn on c6
it seems like he did oh maybe not
so c4 Queen c2 95 now Ben the thing
about these very profound strategic
openings is that for blitz they're kind
of hard to play because you have to play
on something very tiny and in blitz
things can get crazy very quickly well
let's let's ask the man himself how it
happened welcome into the show at this
time
Kenny Solomon of South Africa welcome
back to the show it's great to have you
back on thanks it's good it's good to be
back so you are in a race to second
place right now it seems oh that's what
I mean by Sammy's is really is a real
world class and it's gonna be not not
competing with him so it's it's a race
for second but is second and third so
yeah I think I was trading my teeth
three oh three points about three or
four points and my strategy today was
basically just to catch up in the Blitz
so yeah I feel a very good thing yeah
definitely now psyche this is a
grandmaster Robert when gaskey now you
are in a fight for second place but
right on your healed heels is a hadoo Sh
now you just played a very exciting game
against him earlier today how do you
feel about your chances tomorrow because
you guys have to play another game yeah
yeah we've played in the rapid and they
first first we'll go to blitz mm-hmm so
we more or less I have an idea which
other style of play no I think I've good
trances what do you think his style is
like where
where would you try to guide the game
what kind of traditional you want to
make him play I think I'll try to play
very sharp position because knowing in
the rapid event it was strategically it
was work very strong with black pieces
and he was out playing me and I managed
to escape what what some tactics managed
to create some play for some chicks and
a basically escaped and today I escaped
the game because he had the white pieces
this time that means the Bloods came and
he was squeezing me I was a porn down
which I managed to save in the end game
yeah that was my pawn structure some
didn't look very good going into that
end game but it looks like you were able
to sacrifice some pawns and get active
yeah I'm in a couple of my jumps in and
okay's extra pawn was the double F pawn
and and that allowed me basically to
pull to escape with the draw so I think
my fancy my trances more in tactical
skirmishes okay and also we were
watching the live video in the time
scramble it seemed like your opponent
was like raising his hands or something
you know was he was he making a claim or
what was going on did you notice that at
all that's very clear it was a tense
battle and I offered I offered him a
draw
okay that's a I didn't do it correctly
because you're supposed to move then off
of the draw and then press the clock but
we both had like about six seconds and
we were going around with a king at
night in that forty cave he's not making
progress and offering a draw but you
know it's everything is so fast
two seconds no it's not like you're
getting extra time so yeah so off the
game II he was saying that I had to draw
too many times okay that was the problem
and and what do you think of the the
time delay are you used to playing with
time delay as opposed to mean correct
this was the first time we had a taste
of us in the rapid draws a 10-second
delay
but for three-second delay it's it's
more amped up it's really it's really
tense and in fact in the earlier rounds
of my gimmick in spy he made an illegal
move and we were both under the
impression that I won the game but that
that's all rules right yeah extra minute
yeah we are still basically adapting to
the new rules and the three-second delay
which is which is quite interesting
actually and more difficult to play my
opinion mm-hmm and I liked it all right
agreed well and thanks a lot and good
luck tomorrow thank you so much
all right that's Grandmaster Kenny
Sullivan of South Africa regular on this
little broadcast of ours and for good
reason as he competes to try to get into
a solid second contention mm-hmm now at
this time though we have for the man who
is looking at solid first of course
we're talking about Grandmaster bossom
amine welcome back to the show
once again so we were looking at your
amazing streak which was nine games long
and covering will cross it over from
rabbit to blitz and ended in a draw but
it's still an amazing performance in
this tournament only defeated did you
expect this coming
yeah I'm really happy with my
performance today because yeah most of
the game are very tough intense okay I
think I started to get to be tired
starting from round six I think my game
was fear was quite paradise in yeah it
should have at least thrown yeah maybe
was clearly but at some point but yeah I
was happy to win this and okay then last
three rounds I started to yeah play a
bit slow I would say cause in first
games I was playing fast and and Butch's
hunt was always ahead on the clock
now then I started to slow down a little
bit but yes I'm happy you know in terms
of mine with no losses course a great
result for me okay getting so close from
winning the tournament
makes me a bit more relaxed it tomorrow
you know just okay for to save my rating
and doing some points now this this poor
man is five minutes of a three second
delay but I like to ask people when you
play blitz casually what's your favorite
blitz time control on board well I
prefer three plus two yes that's the
best position just you know liking
people you know and stuff like that I
don't like yeah I possum this is a
Robert can gas key again congratulations
on your fantastic winning streak I'm not
gonna ask you specifically about your
games because the games speak for
themselves but I did want it I point out
that there seems to be a pattern in your
games that with white you play the Kings
Indian attack and when black we play the
Kings Indian defense was it Oh
we dropped the call okay well we'll get
him back in just a moment I was just
gonna ask my super question to it's like
I said I set it up perfectly and I was
about to you know bring it all home we
have some time we have some time bring
it home okay here's that groovy Skype
sound and here we go yeah we're back
right so I was at I was gonna ask you is
this a strategy that you use for for
rapid and blitz in general that you'll
play the same type of systems with white
and blacks
we're yeah actually I'm playing using an
attack I'm defense in classical games -
all right so it's not just limited to
two blitz and rabbit because it seems
like it does make your life easier
because you might not have to think so
much in the opening you know where all
the pieces go and what kind of pawn
structures are good and which
you should avoid so I think there's a
lot of practical value to that it's
actually extra good and rapid and it's
because I know the setups quite well and
it's also not familiar I mean for my
parents they don't usually especially
Kings Indian attack so it's a bit
familiar for me more than they're used
to play so I think it'd give me some
edge you know specially in this tool to
get some extra times of me yeah
absolutely
so that was my sort of insight into this
success a box of amines well in this leg
of the impressive Lego 2 tournament yes
indeed and there's just one more day to
go it was by some we look forward to
seeing some of your games and probably
talking to you again tomorrow thank you
for joining us all right good luck thank
you
all right from Egypt the African
champion the whole continent awesome I
mean yeah so let's let's look at some of
the other games that happen in our final
round we have a little bit of time line
okay and we did not look at too much yet
so where should we start let's see we
have that draw that endgame that we saw
fizzle out into a draw I possum Amin we
saw we didn't see the Kenny Solomon game
to its completion right we were more or
less up to this point when we started
our interview with him and it seemed
like White's position was good but I was
feeling a little bit like okay you're
playing for like a very minimal
strategic advantage in a crazy blitz
game that might not be the best strategy
if we compare for example to bossom am
you strategy of playing like the same
system with white and black playing it
really fast not worrying too much about
getting an advantage just you know
getting your pieces out and maybe
getting a little bit of a time edge on
the clock as well but anyway this paid
off for Solomon because he got a
fantastic position we see these white
knights in the center completely
dominating the board and i know ii v
especially heading for the c6 outpost
and soon
this evolved into a nice tactical shot
because after Queen e7 queen bee to take
stakes I played g5 thinking that he
could push back the white knights but he
ran into this 97 check Minh so if you
play Queen takes your rook is
unprotected and if you move your king
now this night doesn't have to retreat
it can just take your central pawn and
after this white was completely winning
black played c3 Queen c2 rook a3 and
after rook takes he resigned because he
thought he had to move Queen takes a
three but there's a knight on e7 so not
quite a blooper because I think the
positions already lost but still kind of
a funny move right rook a3 they just
take her Brooke yeah I mean it is kind
of funny so that was the move that
catapulted Solomon to second place let's
see what else we have
did we look at we did follow the rocker
tomorrow game which one I keep freaking
her tomorrow
you know once this tournament is over I
bet I'm just gonna like nail it and then
I'll have nobody to say it to so it's
usually how it works yeah yeah so we saw
this one we did see this one what about
the Ella nany against Ole adopt would do
game this one so d4 d69 of 3 g6 pretty
straightforward London system and Ella
Donnie sort of taking the bossom Amin
approach and playing the London system
as white and pretty much all of his
games they think and what that is one of
the big advantages of the London system
a system despised by all chest coaches
around the world because this is where
you put too much emphasis on the
practical value of an opening as opposed
to some of the long
benefits of studying you know some of
the main lines like we were just talking
about these minority attacks lead to
very rich pawn structures so it's
important if you like the London system
not to abuse it but it's it is ideal for
blitz and rapid so this is usually
worked out well for Ellen Ani but not in
this game
now after night c4 Knight h5 Queen c2
rook d8 Bishop f1 Bishop c6
this Bishop on h2 that's usually so
strong maybe not having such a good time
at the moment because black is gonna be
able to play f6 in this Bishop on h2
will be biting on granny that's what I
like to call it when a bishop runs into
a powerful launching by the opponent so
be fine takes takes and it looks like
all the whites pieces are getting pushed
back little by little I'm not so crazy
about this blacks gaining space maybe
securing the future outpost on d3 for
the night and now after 95 Queen b7
Bishop d2 Knight f6 takes takes Bishop
f3 and look at the quality of these
bishops way superior than the bishops on
h2 and f3 so already Black has a nice
advantage here let's see this game
didn't last much longer it looks like
ah-so blundered the e4 pawn and after
Queen takes b5 Queen e2 maybe he thought
this wasn't a blunder because he gets
the b5 pawn but now after rook f1 this
Bishop on h2 is like a fat pawn and
imagine you had three pawns here on F 2
G 2 and H 2 you might have some
background problems because your King
would like to escape via h2 but he can't
so after rook the 8th like threatening
rook t1 and checkmate
Wow how are you gonna deal with this is
there a way to deal with it that's what
I want to do well I was thinking maybe
Queen a4 is the only move here because
you have to stop rook d1 but here even
though I don't have rook e1 I could go
root D
- and start cleaning out your
second-ranked right and take on B -
maybe later take on c3 and push the C
pawn instead white played b3 and after
rook d1 can't stop checkmate
so you resigned yep I like that like
that
I do you do I do with your victory and I
think we just have that brings us to our
last game right yep
Andrew K owned a and David Silva now you
know I haven't really talked about David
Silva too much and I really should from
luanda angola the triple african junior
champion 20 years old and of course we
know very lot about Andrew ko and a
yesterday they had a draw let's see it
alright so we have a Kings Indian Bishop
chief and this is called the Abra Bach
variation water urea Baba
after URI Auerbach now I believe he is
the only one that is still alive from
that golden era of chess I mean you have
Spassky as well but there you can count
them in one hand
when does the golden era end that's a
good question okay yeah it seems a
little arbitrary it is a little bit
arbitrary but I'm just gonna call it the
golden era cuz it sounds you know like
I'm paying reverence yeah sure great
generator I'm chess players so c5 d5 and
this is generally a technique that I
like to employ against the Kings Indian
the Kings Indian basically wants us to
close the center and Castle King sites
so that black can just attack us for
free and what I like to do is white is
not that so in general with any opening
I try to figure out well what is why my
opponent want me to do and then I'll
just won't I'll do anything about that
just to frustrate them and here the
armor back variation has no intention of
castling kingside
so it's the reason why I think it's one
of the most challenging setups against
the Kings indeed
now black has changed his opening
strategy from King's Indian to benoni
by combining this c5 and c6 moves so
after Knight f3 takes takes normally you
don't want to take with your a point you
want to go see takes d5 and at some
point try to prepare this ePHI pawn
advance but I'm guessing why it was a
little bit concerned with the move rook
e8 but here I might be able to go a 5
anyway and this is actually exactly the
kind of position white is aiming for in
the Benoni pawn structures right this
powerful pawn center now maybe after 94
we can't really keep our pawns on d5 an
e5 but maybe we can you know start doing
some annoying things like sacrificing
this pawn and going d6 maybe kicking
this Knight out going Castle we're down
a pawn but we have a powerful pawn on d6
threatening d7 by the way we also have
better pawn structure so I don't like
eat akes d5 I think this allows black to
really play a much freer game because he
never has to worry about this annoying
ePHI pawn break 94 takes takes rook e1
night before b3 a 5 yeah I think Black
has solved pretty much is opening
problems Bishop a5 Bishop e2 and I guess
this is how the draw came about just to
move repetition both sides trying to
save themselves for the final day so
it's gonna be a great day tomorrow
I feel like I'm having a Revenge of the
Nerds moment it's gonna be a great year
never seen them you never seen it no and
I'm like a pretty big movie guy yeah
it's a great I've been saving it well so
we've had a lot of action today of
course hopefully you tuned in earlier
today and saw the seven rounds that we
weren't live for but if you've been
enjoying what you're seeing in this
tournament remember this is the same
format as the rapid and blitz events in
the Grand chest tour and the grand chest
tour this year has kicked off in a big
way already with the tournament in
Leuven Belgium your next move and then
of course Paris grand chest tour right
after that and in the grand chest or we
have two Americans at the top and I tell
you this because the grand chest tour is
coming to st. Louis Missouri quite soon
with back-to-back events I'm talking
about the st. Louis rapid and blitz and
then the Sinquefield come now this is
the second annual st. Louis rapid and
blitz will be having which the
festivities kick off on August 10th at
Grantchester org round one I believe is
on the 11th the Sinquefield Cup is right
after that which is the only pure
classical event on the grand chest tour
this year and then the the combined
score from the tour the top four players
will meet in London in December
tentatively December for the grand chess
Tour Championship now if you want to see
these games and you're stateside or
you're not stateside cuz st. Louis it's
great here if the st. Louis chess club
we'd certainly invite you the
tournaments are back to back August 10th
through August 28th the st. Louis rapid
and blitz and the Sinquefield Cup and
interesting it up you know Wesley so has
21 grand chests or points Hikaru
Nakamura has 20 they're at the top of
the leaderboard but at the very bottom
of the leaderboard is Fabiano Cara Juana
with just four grand chests or points
he's a realistically eliminated from
contention and it's hardly any chance he
goes to London for the final but the
intrigue starts in st. Louis because the
chests or wild card for the Sinquefield
cup has been announced and it is none
other than the world chess champion
himself Magnus Carlsen oh that will mean
that in a classical game here in st.
Louis next month we will see Cara Juana
versus Carlson as a part of the
Sinquefield Cup and can Bobby hold it
together that's what I want to know do
you say that's gonna be like a prelude
to the world that will be game zero the
preview for the World Chess Championship
coming to place and London my god London
has both the London classic Final Four
the grand chest or and the world
championship and they're probably gonna
be like back-to-back so I mean Fabiano
might not make it to the grand chest for
final but like what if he did like I
have to like them to London for a while
yeah like it's gonna be crazy we hope
you can join that join us for that at
Grantchester org but we're not there yet
we still have one more day of blitz in
this grand chest war style the event I'm
talking about the cote d'ivoire a rapid
and blitz invitational join us tomorrow
you'll notice that we're on the air two
hours early here I want you to take
everything that you know about the time
that we started and throw it away yeah
oh no that's an important sheet but
tomorrow 16 15 UTC we'll be on the air
with you and remember the games start
even earlier than that you can go on
chess 24 comm and check out the seven
rounds of blitz we will not be
presenting to you live but we will be
glancing at some special games we'll
bossom a mean mathematically clinch the
event before we go on the air yeah it's
over not even a possibility no no okay
that second place should be fun and I
like doing these interviews so come
watch me do interviews yes I feel like I
get along with Kenny like we would be
buddies if we just hire what wouldn't be
buddies with him what I know him
personally no but I feel like I do yeah
me too
yeah okay okay pardon me well ladies and
gentlemen thank you so much for joining
us this show was produced by
world's greatest production b-team Tammy
Hyde is a technical adviser Isaac's
ronsis on audio and graphics Dennis
LaRue is our technical director I'm Ben
Simon this is Robert Kahn gaskey going
over there signing off
so that'll do it until tomorrow two
hours early be with us here at Chester
24 calm until then we say so long from
the Show Me State
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you